Well, it's a Sunday and I'm at Parque Pilares.
This is a popular place for people to get together
and play pick-up games.
Mexicans pride themselves
on being the very best at futbol.
Well, this gringo's here to school them.
(audience laughing)
I'm going to arrive an unknown and leave a legend.
Ola.
Hola, how are you?
Como estas, I'm fine.
How are you?
Do you have any questions for me about my abilities?
Yeah, how good are you?
Well, I played once in summer camp, 1974.
Okay, that was a long time ago.
Well, relatively if you're thinking about
geological history, no.
Pretty recent.
Have you ever kicked something?
I did, I kicked an old man once.
And is he okay?
Oh, he beat the shit out of me.
Ah, okay.
(Mexican traditional music)
(Conan shouting)
I did it!
I deflected the ball!
(players clapping)
Conan! Conan!
(Conan shouting)
(distorted shouting)
I have one question, do you have oxygen in a tank?
No.
Guys, I feel guilty.
I don't feel like I'm helping the team
as much as I should.
We know that.
You know that?
Yes.
Es posible, can I please go and get a friend
to help our team?
Is that okay?
Oh please.
Yeah, sure.
I'll be right back, stay right here.
Okay.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Oh!
Giovani!
(applauding)
Wow!
This is my friend.
He says he plays a little bit of futbol.
Giovani, do you know these guys?
How are you, my friend?
Giovani.
So you're on my team.
Yes.
Right?
Yeah.
And we go against the other team.
And maybe we do a little better this time.
Okay, yeah.
What do you think?
You okay with it?
I'm perfect.
You're perfect?
Let's do it.
What's the plan?
What do you want me to do?
Yes!
(laughing)
Giovani, Conan O'Brien.
Conan!
Gio.
Gio!
Goal!
Yes! Yes! Yes!
Conan, Conan, Conan!
Goal!
(audience cheering and applauding)
What did you learn from me today
when playing football?
To you?
Yeah. What skills?
You saw some of my tricks.
What did you learn?
I think your first touch, great.
First touch,
my first touch is great.
Your first touch is great.
People will say--
And also
I'm agile like a cat, el gato.
They call me el gato.
El gato, yeah.
El gato.
You brought so much joy today here
to everyone who plays.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I have a jersey, a Mexican Jersey for you.
Oh wow look at this!
Mexican jersey.
Look at this!
(cheering and applauding)
Thank you for coming to my country.
Oh my God.
And look at that, they put my name on the back.
I will wear this.
You have to wear it.
When we play against United States?
Yes.
You have to wear it.
I will wear this.
Okay?
I will wear this and I will play on your team.
Do you want that?
Perfect.